when I play Bach I try to make the
dances a dance and make them all really
lively and light and think about how
they would have been played in the
Baroque era of course now that we have
the piano compared to the harpsichord or
the clavichord there's a completely
different sound so I wouldn't try to
imitate the harpsichord but we still
want to keep some of the essence of the
harpsichord in it so I like to play with
like some of the timings in it because
on harpsichord there's no dynamics so
all you can do is with timing and with
touch and articulation so I like to
bring it some of those aspects on to the
piano and but keep it in the Baroque
style while having a piano sound
I think one I know I have a lot of
friends who also play instruments and
mainly their reason for not liking Bach
is because it's so hard but I'd like to
encourage them to explore more of it
because it's hard so that they can
discover something new within each piece
and hopefully they can use that and take
it and apply it to other composers so
that's also helpful I think it's a good
way to help people learn how to
multitask because you have to deal with
so many different voices that's once and
they all have to be really clean it's
also just really fun to play and it
helps you improve your technique there's
so many running lines I mean you have to
practice them at first of course but
after a while when you get the hang of
it it's really fun to just see your
hands moving all the way over the key
work
I usually work on pieces for at least a
year I mean I start I listen to them
when I first start playing them and I
listen for which ones I like so I'll
pick them up find the music and just
start working on them by myself and
usually it takes me about a year or so
to get some good practicing in to get
some good understanding about the piece
and then after that of course during
that time I've worked with my teachers
but after that we'll start preparing it
to use maybe for performances or other
things like that